you know this is the monster in this box
right here and we need to make sure the
monster is creepy and it works really
good job there so over the last couple
weeks we've been prepping for this Ghost
Hunters video basically we're Sam and
Nico are ghost hunters and they get
asked by their friend Wes to solve this
mystery and in the process Sam gets
attacked by this monster and his face
turns into the monsters face but in
order to pull that off
we're gonna have to employ some
unorthodox special-effects techniques
toxic clay yeah put this on my head have
you seen samsara you know this the the
sequel to Baraka remember that art piece
in the middle of it where that office
worker starts smearing clay all over his
face and he like you know use his
paintbrushes to cut like a joker mouth
into his lips and then he just ends up
slathering clay all over his head until
he looks like the creature from Pan's
Labyrinth remember that
you know this is the monster in this box
right here and we need to make sure the
monster is creepy and works today we
will be testing that Sam's busy you need
two things you need water and you need
clay and you basically mix them together
and you slather it on your face and you
build it up and you punch tools for the
eyes and not hold for your mouth and
you're a creepy monster are you excited
about your acting opportunity
apprehensive clinton wants to shoot this
in a legitimately dank sewer if I'm
gonna be stuck in a dank sewer for like
an hour or two I really don't want to
have it all over my face for like two
hours while I'm in a dank dark sewer you
should be the guy that good job why does
it have to be me my worst fear is didn't
have to do the Travis we're gonna
actually make trapped blind in a
legitimately abandoned sewer with that
on my face for more than like a half
hour I might freak out I might become
the monster
today we're filming in an abandoned
tunnel and it's down in a dam the
logistics of today are a little crazy
going underground I got to find some
ladders packed all of our production
here into backpacks now it's getting
kind of weird with climbing fences
yeah who wants to go down first
oh my god yeah easy I'm gonna hand me
that bag the days of guerilla filmmaking
Jesus - I'm getting vertigo right now in
the 70s
four children went missing and they
found the kidnapper he told them where
the the bodies were which makes him a
murderer and they found two of the
bodies here in this tunnel right here I
believe so here's the scariest part four
children went missing they found two of
the bodies where are the other two right
there I don't want to be in this dank
tunnel what if something goes wrong out
here I'm either gonna be sleeping with
the fishes tonight and would be falling
off the cliffs come come with us on a
journey and witness the end of my acting
career I'm not doing it until we're
ready - like we are trying to multitask
looks like the inside of my son's diaper
not all art has to be passionate
sometimes you just have to man up and
smear it all over your face and it's
okay to not like it but it's not okay to
back away and not do it
keep wiping this stuff over your face
you basically want to get like an inch
of goo over everything that's what we're
going for
that's the face you know I mean I
actually wouldn't mind being that guy
either what Sam's doing I think that'd
be you know kind of fun you know what is
what is ten minutes discomfort for
lifetime with stories
are unable to breathe guys only
hibernating in here are you breath
stuff
[Music]
shambo's
are you short of breath yeah
yeah it's just what my nose got sealed
off like my you know my my ear pressure
they're like my depression my ears yeah
actually I was unable to like fix it
like just my ears were permanently there
so the clay was a bit trickier than we
thought
kind of had a small panic attack just a
little bit we were able to unclog Sam's
offices and get our shots we have a
whole other day with this mask and I
don't want to make Sam go through this
again so we're gonna have to just figure
something else out well I think we're
doing it today I'm good yeah this is
interesting it is very interesting what
else you guys realize how long you Brett
have known each other a long time we met
in like 2005 4-3 or something like that
yeah like 2004 so how you doing dude
Brett's not technically in this brand is
accredited in us as a creature stunt
double is playing Sam who has the
creature on his face so you think you
you were there the day I was there how'd
it go in your opinion they just put a
bunch of clay right on her face okay I'm
pretty good at breathing underwater for
a long time so we'll see yeah it should
be okay well I'll talk to Sam a little
bit I asked him if he had well I heard
he had a hard time so I asked him if he
had any recommendations so other than
the brief moment of suffocation that I
had to endure he got in my ears you
don't want to clamp your nose you don't
clean your mouth because then you can't
breathe you know simple advice like you
all them earlier it's like okay Sam I'm
like Robert Pattinson asking Christian
Belt
the next bet and one of my ears was like
clogged for 24 hours and I had to like
pick away at it with like q-tips for
like a whole weekend even on Monday
I've still don't like pulling clay
chunks out of my ear and it was so
annoying so now we got a whole five
gallon bucket just with this mud so I
got the coffee Christian he said yeah
basically putting clay on your face I
was like okay he said you know there's
certain things in life that you wish you
know - yeah a hashtag thankful no I
there are no small roles there are only
small actors working with creatures I
love kooky characters and I love the
fact that I'm not under it really good
job I really appreciated Christian Brett
what whoa
that's me
is it you're looking pretty good thank
you in here with your hand Brett so you
know it's like bull open your mouth wide
ya little cheek action I'm gonna smooth
over this front part okay take a deep
breath give me one of the red bulls and
win them straws over there I'd like one
oh I do love blueberry miss lane mama
used to make to me professionalism is
showing up on the day with your best
ideas and executing those ideas to the
best of your ability despite the
hardships and despite how you're feeling
that day it's getting the job done that
is the work of a professional shout outs
to Bret and shout outs to Sam for going
through that and do what they had to do
for the team for the video thank you the
videos actually out right now please go
give it a look we put a lot of hard work
into this video there's a lot of pain
and suffering and stress that went into
this thing so the link is in the
description you guys know how to work
YouTube we've been doing it for like 12
years so yeah enjoy today is the last
day to order the anime self-driving cars
shirt reissue for this weekend only we
had it live and it is Sunday February
28th the day this video is uploaded is
your last day to order one we're going
to make the number of shirts so we have
orders for good news we won't be sold
out bad news after today you can't order
it anymore corridor digital dot store
links in the description below it's our
best selling fruit of all time you will
love it it's a great shirt go check it
out go to digital deaths store and as
always thank you so much for your
support it's really really cool running
into people in the wild wearing our
merch anyways quarter digital dot store
and I'm a self-driving car shirt today's
your last day later